and we should know we visited with
families taking shelter inside the
george r brown convention center behind
me one woman we spoke to yesterday was
watching over her family after an
uncomfortable welcome the night before
did they have any beds for you no ma'am
and you have how many kids six
so where did everybody sleep on the
floor i stayed um up in the chair i
didn't sleep
but my baby slept on the floor
oh yeah
yes now
all of them i got some they ran out of
blankets so we had got a bunch of towels
and propped them up to make it be
comfortable and we just made a big
pallet on the floor people came here
with
no clothing they didn't even have shoes
and the call went out for donations and
this is what resulted
there are mountains of these clothes
about half a dozen of these just huge
piles of clothes i went to the table
they gave us two
little things for them a piece and they
told us like when uh when they were
those to come back and they gave them
some pampers and wipes they did they
gave us that you think the city should
have been more prepared yes when
the mayor said
don't leave he didn't think it was gonna
be that bad i'm like okay
so but after that when they start coming
in i just knew it was alive i never been
through nothing like that charlie you're
running this shelter here correct how's
it going
you know it's going as well as it can be
with the conditions we're meeting the
immediate emergency needs of all the
clients um and we're just keeping up
you're just keeping up we're meeting all
of the needs of the clients but it's
going about as well as we could expect
it to
mark strassman joins me he's also been
inside the convention center you heard
the man running the red cross he said
they're they're just keeping up one of
the problems has been getting supplies
and how are they making sure that the
trucks that have the cots and other
supplies can get in
there are no guarantees i mean let's
face it i think i think they're working
hard and they're crossing the fingers
that the water's good out so the trucks
can get in but we followed these four
walmart trucks with donated supplies
food and water took them two days to get
in they finally get to the back of this
convention center to to drop it off
there's no place to unload because there
are too many people
who are now living in spaces where the
supplies would be would be left so
they've got a series of logistical
challenges and that's going to keep on
going
one of the things that has eased
pressure on the convention centers now
they've opened up this other
uh shelter
um how big is that going to grow well
it's they're two different uh centers
it's there's where the houston rockets
play and where the houston texans play
ten thousand uh evacuees at one
potentially five thousand potentially at
the other uh that's going to ease
pressure here there are fewer folks here
maybe a thousand fifteen hundred fewer
folks at the convention center than they
were yesterday but at the same time you
still got to feed these people get them
shelter get them cots get them supplies
and in some respects the logistical
challenges multiply at that point
because you have drop-off points not at
one place but at multiple places again
the biggest thing that would really help
is for these waters to start going down
having spent days only going up thank
you mark so
gail you hear just a lot of challenges
still ahead here in houston to take care
of all those who've been rescued from
their homes
nora thank you i know you're heading
back to new york but i just want to say
again what a great job you and your team
have done you know you guys have really
painted a picture for us i think when
the story first started we all thought
okay it's heavy rain they'll be okay but
you're really taking us behind the
scenes to show us how bad it's been
there how cold the weather is for the
people they come with soaking wet
clothes and nothing to do and nowhere to
go and i know too it must have affected
you the things that you have seen
yeah you know it's um i felt strongly
that people should see what happens
meaning our viewers should see what
happens when you're inside uh a shelter
like this the type of care they are
receiving or not receiving and it's hard
it's really hard on people and i think
one of the things to remember is
volunteers showed up in droves there was
lines of people who wanted to go stay
inside and there were lines of people
who wanted to go help inside and that's
a reminder about the strength of the
texas spirit all right nora o'donnell
thank you very much safe travels back
home to new york we look forward to
seeing you